Hey everybody, we are here in London
at the Long Cross studios
to visit the set of Now You See Me 2.
This is the sequel to the 2013,
incredibly successful,
bank heist flick.
So, how did they pull off all
of those incredible illusions?
Well, that's what we're here
to find out. Let's go inside.
My magic trick here is when
I want things to disappear,
I just say, "Cut."
What? (LAUGHING)
When I do it it's just magic
and then you just
-go like that or just point to it.
-(LAUGHING)
I'm here with Dave Franco.
So this is obviously
-your second time back.
-Yes.
How does it feel being back on set
with some of the same actors?
DAVE: It's very uncomfortable.
It's just a lot of man love,
-and uh--
-(LAUGHING)
I thought you were about to say
it's uncomfortable,
and you don't like the cast.
(LAUGHING)
-No, no, no.
-But the level of love
-is uncomfortable.
-Yes, exactly.
Probably makes everyone around us
uncomfortable.
Did you ever expect to be here again
filming a second part?
JESSE: It didn't cross my mind,
but it's the kind of movie
that can lend itself to a sequel
'cause it's all created mythology.
You know, it takes place
in this world that's both
of the real world and also created,
so it makes sense that the story
can continue past where
the first one ended.
TIFFANY: How does it feel being
the new kid on the block
with everybody who's worked
on it,
who has a little more
practice already with the magic?
Oh, I've already lapped them
when it comes to magic.
-What?
-Yeah, instantly.
Uh, no, it doesn't--
I guess it's a--
It's a testament to how fun
this job is that I keep forgetting
that I wasn't in the first one
and that I'm the new person.
With a movie,
there's many different tricks
and we're so used to crazy
visual effects, that we really put
a lot of pressure on making sure
that everything was practical
and that when you see it,
we're not cutting around;
we're not cheating you.
Uh, that you actually get
to experience the magic
as if you were there in person.
And use the friction
to kind of flick it up.
-Perfect. Perfect.
-(LAUGHING)
Dave is actually amazing.
-What?
-Pretty cool, huh?
JON: I thought it was not possible
from an actor on, in camera.
Uh, the truth is all the really great
illusions in the movie,
uh, are hand doubles, people who are
really wonderful like this man here.
(LAUGHING) Do you want him
to be your hand double
-for this interview?
-Yeah, exactly.
I heard that you actually
have been working a little bit
-on the mentalist side?
-(LAUGHING)
-Or like...mind readings? (LAUGHING)
-No, I'm horrible.
I'm the worst at it,
but hopefully one day
I can hypnotize somebody
in some way.
Come see the movie.
It's really great.